my name is jeanne shaheen
originally I'm from Missouri i was born
in st. Charles Missouri grew up in
southern Missouri in the boot heel and
went to high school in college in
pennsylvania my family moved east and i
sort of worked my way northeast and then
went up to the coast of maine after i
got out of college and met my husband
who's from new hampshire so i've spent
the last for almost 40 years in new
hampshire you know i think one of the
things that moving around a lot as a
child did was it gave me a greater
appreciation for the differences among
people and a greater tolerance for the
fact that everybody isn't the same that
not only do we look different but we
have different perspectives and
different backgrounds and different
values and that it's important to be
tolerant of that
well I think certainly my parents were a
great influence and my grandfather was
also a big influence my grandfather was
this outsized figure who still rode
horses into a 60s in had farm where he
had cattle he drove a pickup truck that
had horns on the front of it and when he
blew the horn and the truck it mood and
he always wore a string tie and a cowboy
hat so he was quite a character and
someone who I looked up to I think he
always had me tag along with him and so
I think he took an interest in me I was
very much a tom boy growing up and very
interested in horses and cows and the
farm and what was going on and I think
he he found that interesting and I
thought people in the community also
looked up to him his nickname was boss
and I always found that very interesting
when we would go into the bank or a
store that it was clear that people
listened to what he had to say